House of the Dragon, a Game of Thrones prequel
show, is coming in 2022 on HBO and beside
Targaryens themselves, Targaryen dragons will
also play a major role in this upcoming epic
series.
Game of Thrones had only 3 dragons and it
was a game changer.
House of the Dragon will feature over 20 dragons
and even more epic dragon fights.
Dragons are the reason that the dragonlord
Targaryen family frequently married brother
to sister
to keep the bloodline pure
as it is generally believed that Valyrian
heritage plays a part in bonding with a dragon.
Provided it has food and freedom, a dragon
never stops growing.
The lifespan of dragons is many times that
of a human, although their maximum natural
lifespan is difficult to determine: as beasts
of war, most of the known examples died in
battle.
Balerion, the largest and oldest Targaryen
dragon, already alive when House Targaryen
relocated from Valyria to Dragonstone in 114
BC died of old age in 94 AC.
Balerion was near two hundred years of age
when he died, but as the only known example
of a dragon who died of old age, it is unclear
if this should be considered typical.
The Valyrians had thousands of dragons.
After the Doom of Valyria, however, the only
dragons known to have survived were five dragons
on Dragonstone.
They belonged to House Targaryen, who had
brought them from Valyria when they went into
exile.
Four of these dragons eventually died on Dragonstone,
leaving only Balerion.
However, the other dragons left eggs behind,
and from these hatched Vhagar and Meraxes.
Balerion, called the Black Dread, was ridden
by King Aegon I Targaryen during his Conquest.
Balerion was the largest and oldest Targaryen
dragon ever.
His wingspan was so large that his shadow
could engulf entire towns when he passed overhead.
His teeth were as long as swords, and his
jaws were large enough to swallow a mammoth.
Beside by Aegon the Conqueror, Balerion was
also ridden by Maegor the Cruel, Princess
Aerea Targaryen and King Viserys I Targaryen.
Balerion's scales and wings were black.
His fire was black as well.
When he was in the fullness of his power,
his flames could melt steel and stone, and
fuse sand into glass.
House Targaryen used Balerion, Vhagar, and
Meraxes in their Wars of Conquest against
the Seven Kingdoms.
They were instrumental in the burning of Harrenhal
and the Field of Fire, and the threat of dragons
led to the submissions of Torrhen Stark and
Sharra Arryn.
Dragons were also used in the First Dornish
War, which caused the death of Meraxes at
the Hellholt in 10 AC.
She was ridden by Queen Rhaenys Targaryen
and was named for one of the gods of Old Valyria.
Meraxes was larger than Vhagar, but smaller
than Balerion.
She could swallow horses whole.
Meraxes had golden eyes and silver scales.
While being ridden by Queen Rhaenys in their
invasion of Dorne, an iron bolt from a scorpion
went through Meraxes's eye, and the dragon
and Rhaenys fell from the sky to their deaths.
Many dragons were hatched after Aegon's Conquest.
During Aegon I's reign, "half a dozen" hatchlings
were born on Dragonstone.
One of the first was Quicksilver, hatched
in 7 AC, who bonded with Aegon I's elder son
and heir, Aenys.
Quarter the size of Balerion, her fireballs
were pale white in color.
Quicksilver died in 43 AC in what became the
first time since the Doom of Valyria that
a dragon fought dragon.
In the battle Beneath the Gods Eye, Aegon
the Conqueror's grandson, also named Aegon,
attempted to win back the throne that by rights
was his, but both Quicksilver and Aegon died
fighting Maegor upon his dragon Balerion.
Balerion grabbed Quicksilver's throat in his
jaws, then ripped one of Quicksilver's wings
from its body in mid-air, after which Quicksilver
fell to its death, along with young Aegon.
Over the course of one hundred and fifty years
the Targaryens rode their dragons as a symbol
of their power.
King Jaehaerys I Targaryen took six dragons
with him to Winterfell to visit the Warden
of the North.
These included Jaehaerys on Vermithor, Queen
Alysanne on Silverwing, and four other currently-unknown
dragons.
Vermithor, called the Bronze Fury, was a male
dragon.
Vermithor was already a large dragon in 48
AC.
Only larger were Balerion and Vhagar.
By the time of the Dance of the Dragons, Vermithor
was almost a hundred years old.
Balerion finally died of old age in 94 AC,
late in the reign of Jaehaerys I. Jaehaerys's
grandson and eventual successor Viserys I
was Balerion's rider at the time of its death.
This left Vhagar as the largest living dragon,
and by 129 AC she was approaching Balerion's
size.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive.
The majority of these died during the civil
war called the Dance of the Dragons, which
began in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne.
When people started declaring for one of them
or the other, their fight divided the kingdoms
in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
The conflict would prove to be incredibly
destructive for not only House Targaryen,
but large parts of Westeros as well.
In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
The largest and oldest dragons during the
Targaryen civil war were Vhagar, Vermithor,
Silverwing, Dreamfyre, Meleys, Caraxes, and
Syrax.
The younger dragons still large enough to
be ridden to war were Seasmoke, Sunfyre, Tessarion,
Vermax, Arrax, Tyraxes, and Moondancer.
Stormcloud, Morghul, and Shrykos were hatchlings
not yet big enough to ride.
There were also three wild dragons living
on Dragonstone which had never been successfully
claimed by any rider: Grey Ghost, Sheepstealer,
and the Cannibal.
Syrax was Rhaenyra Targaryen's dragon.
Her name came from a goddess of Valyria.
Syrax had yellow scales.
She was huge and formidable, but not as fearsome
or experienced in battle as Daemon's Caraxes.
She was kept in chains and exceedingly well
fed.
Syrax was slain in the aftermath of the Storming
of the Dragonpit.
Prince Joffrey had attempted to mount her
to ride to the Dragonpit, save the other dragons,
and perhaps mount his own dragon Tyraxes there.
However, dragons are not horses, and they
will only accept one mount at a time.
In mid-flight, Syrax shrugged off Joffrey,
who fell to his death.
Syrax eventually died fighting the rioters
on the ground.
In 129 AC, after the start of the Dance of
the Dragons, the second biggest dragon alive,
Vermithor bent his neck to a blacksmith’s
bastard called Hugh Hammer.
During the Second Battle of Tumbleton
Addam Velaryon upon the dragon Seasmoke attacked
Vermithor.
Seasmoke was a pale silver-grey dragon.
It was of fighting size during the Dance,
but still a young dragon and nimbler in the
air than his older brothers.
He was of comparable size to Tessarion, who
was about three times smaller than Vermithor,
and not as fearsome a beast as him in comparison.
Just before this, Vermithor's rider was killed.
Vermithor, now riderless, wounded and enraged,
took flight, attacking all those around him.
While Vermithor was only twenty feet above
the field, Seasmoke slammed into him from
above.
The two dragons rolled over the field, so
entangled that neither was able to break free.
Tessarion also entered the fight.
The three dragons fought to the death.
Tessarion, also known as the Blue Queen, was
a she-dragon.
She was ridden by Prince Daeron Targaryen.
Tessarion was a beautiful blue she-dragon
and her flames were cobalt blue in color.
She was one of the smaller fighting dragons.
Vermithor killed Seasmoke when he locked his
teeth into the latter's neck and ripped his
head off.
He attempted to take flight with his prize
still in his jaws, but his wings were tattered,
causing him to be unable to bear the weight.
After a moment he collapsed and died.
Tessarion was the last to die.
On three occasions did she try to fly again,
but failed every time again.
By late afternoon the day after the battle,
she seemed to be in pain.
At the command of Lord Benjicot Blackwood,
his best archer shot three arrows into the
dying dragon's eye, killing her.
The fourth dragon, Silverwing was also there,
but fled into the sky when the battle began.
However after the battle was over, Silverwing
descended to land beside the slain dragons.
Later, the singers would tell of how she tried
to lift dead Vermithor’s wing three times
with her nose, as if to try and make him fly
again.
Silverwing was a silvery she-dragon.
She was ridden by Queen Alysanne Targaryen,
and by Ulf White during the Dance of the Dragons.
Silverwing was the one of only four dragons
still alive at the end of the Targaryen civil
war.
During this time of the Dance of the Dragons,
Vhagar was the hardened survivor of a hundred
battles, had grown almost as large as Balerion,
and was the oldest and largest of the dragons
in Westeros.
Her roar was so powerful that it could shake
the very foundations of Storm's End.
No living dragon could match her for size
or ferocity.
The color of Vhagar's scales, horns, wings,
wing bones, and spinal crest is unknown, as
is the color of her flame.
Prince Aemond was her dragonrider.
At the beginning of the war, Vhagar killed
young dragon Arrax along with its dragonrider
Lucerys.
Arrax was five times smaller than Vhagar.
The storming of the Dragonpit took place during
the riot of King's Landing during the Dance
of the Dragons when the rioters slew 4 dragons:
Shrykos, young dragon unclaimed since the
death of Prince Jaehaerys Targaryen; Morghul,
the dragon of Princess Jaehaera Targaryen;
Tyraxes, the dragon ridden by Prince Joffrey
Velaryon; and pale blue dragon, Dreamfyre,
unclaimed since Queen Helaena Targaryen's
death.
Unable to fly away, as they had been chained,
the four dragons fought with their horns,
claws, and teeth.
They let loose their dragonflame and transformed
the Dragonpit into a fiery inferno.
The first dragon to die was Shrykos, who was
slain by Hobb who leaped onto her neck and
drove his axe down into the dragon's skull.
Next died Morghul, slain by the Burning Knight,
who rushed into the dragon's flame and stabbed
him repeatedly in the eye with his spear as
he burned to his own death.
Tyraxes burned those who rushed at him from
his lair, until the front entrance of his
lair was completely blocked with corpses.
However, the mob broke through the back door
of the dragon's lair and slew him.
Last to die was Dreamfyre.
Dreamfyre was the only dragon able to break
free of her chains when the mob broke in.
She took wing, circled the interior of the
dome and swooped down to attack the men below.
She slew more men than the other three dragons
combined.
Archers and crossbowmen loosed arrows and
quarrels at her, and whenever she landed men
swarmed her to attack, driving her back into
the air.
Eventually one of her eyes was nicked by a
crossbow bolt.
Half-blind and maddened, Dreamfyre flew into
the Dragonpit's great dome above, which cracked
on impact.
Half of it came tumbling down crushing her
and the dragonslayers
under tons of broken stone and rubble.
So many dragons had died in the war that the
Targaryens couldn't maintain a stable breeding
population, and the few survivors became inbred
and sickly.
Fortunatlely, however, the key event of House
of the Dragon is the exact same event which
led to their extinction - the Targaryen civil
war, the Dance of the Dragons and we'll get
to see them all on screen.
Part 2 of this video is coming tomorrow when
I will cover even more dragons, in fact some
of the most epic dragons and their fights.
A lot of dragons, a lot of epic dragon battles,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel series, House of the Dragons brings
in 2022 on HBO.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, the mighty dragons and their
epic battles in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!